was deliberately shot and killed by the
Israeli Army it was no mistake
that's the conclusion of an independent
investigation
it includes previously unseen footage
from May the 11th when Shireen and five
other journalists arrived in the
occupied West Bank City of Janine to
report on an Israeli rate on a refugee
camp
the video shows Shirin and her colleague
Alice samudi working slowly and orderly
towards the Israeli Army position
following standard protocols for members
of the media
but six shots are fired at them at rapid
succession
and Al Jazeera camera keeps rolling as
Ali runs shouting that he is wounded
seconds later Morgan fire
the video captures the last moments of
shireen's life as she crouches near a
wall
then the calls for help Shirin has been
shot
oh
as she lies motionless her colleague
Shada hides behind the tree unable to
reach her
the report reconstructs the position of
the Israeli army unit the armored
vehicles from which Shireen was shot
it points out that the shots were fired
individually meaning that the sniper was
aiming each time
the bullet retrieved from shireen's head
matches the ammunition of the M4 rifles
used by the Israeli snipers its green
tip indicates that it is designed to
pierce body armor
the simulation shows the nearest vehicle
was 190 meters from the spot where
Shirin stood
the journalists press fests would have
been clearly visible
investigators say the close radius of
the bullet holes in nearby tree trunks
are proof of the deliberate attempts to
hit her all are above shoulder height
and according to the report were
intended to kill
a civilian who approaches Shireen as
Sheila is dying is immediately fired at
oh God
when he moves out of the snipers feel
the vision the shooting stops
when he returns it resumes
the report concludes the Israeli Army
targeted The Rescuer deliberately
denying Shireen medical assistance
the sound analysis shows the source of
the gunfire that day was where the
Israeli army unit was stationed and the
images corroborate with those Testaments
that no Fighters were in the vicinity
nor was any Crossfire ahead before or
during the shooting at chirin
investigators conclude three things
Shireen and her colleagues were
explicitly targeted despite being
identifiable as members of the media
the shooter was a sniper firing from an
Israeli army vehicle
and once shot Shirin was deliberately
denied medical attention
in summary the report finds it was a
willful act with a clear Aim Shoot to
kill Muhammad al-jazeera